We know that we're going to write a loop that searches for long words. And we
know that it should stop if you find one. Or if you run out of words. If I just
worry about running out of words at first, I might write my loop as while
in.hasNext. Keep looking. But now, there is an other condition that I have to
meet as well. I have to not have already found the word. So, i want to keep
looping as long as there's an other word and the wrong word is not found. Now
inside the loop, we need to actually get the next word. And then, if this word
we just got is long, then we want to save the word for later, and also make
sure to mark that we've found it, so that we can exit the loop. So far, I
haven't created a variable for saving this, but if I scroll down a little bit,
I can see that I want to print out long word. So, let's make a variable called
long word. Now, in my if statement, I'll update long word and set found to
true. Let's try. It says that the first long word in Alice In Wonderland is
ADVENTURES. That sounds appropriate and I'd say that's an important word to
Alice In Wonderland.